[Music]
hey guys we know you're part of our
Kickstarter and it's been active this
entire month but guess what it's almost
gonna end you have to hurry up go to the
Kickstarter page in the link in the
description get your own box it looks
like this but it's gonna be black and
gold because the Kickstarter exclusive
and then you can also get a t-shirt a
pin whole bunch of cool stuff so don't
forget to check out the link in the
description and winning game strong news
submitted by a furry from Monrovia Oh
get it get it that's too real
that's a Monrovia and squirrel a man
tries to sell a six year old McDonald's
meal on eBay a man dresses so six year
old McDonald's oh I think I was trying
to sell the six year old at McDonald's I
already knew it was but I thought the
same thing to you that's funny is this
still intact like you see in everything
that'd be so cool yeah so that's gross
you guys okay I miss that there you go
again hey you know you know you know
something cool
they sent me a package in a stack like
this big of chicken nuggets and fries
I'll hook you guys up that's tight you
could get you could get it chicken
nuggets and fries you know and and they
they made me a stamp steel so they gave
me all these like candles and then they
gave me a snap with the J on it so I
could melt the wet I couldn't ya melt it
and inspect my jaw mallya we McDonald's
did this yeah they finally listen to you
they finally recognized me how did they
find out about you because I Gena posted
something to make about McDonald's Rosa
yeah and then I was like stop rubbing it
in our face and then they're like we we
we were something like we respect you
your majesty and I was like holy [ __ ]
and then they email me and then they
gave they gave me all kinds of [ __ ] and
they wrote me a personalized letter
recognizing the nation of Joe Mallya do
they know about Joe moly and the poverty
but you know after what four years of us
knocking on their door they finally
they're starting to recognize one by one
something all right
that's kind of cool pretty tight yeah
yeah I want some nuggies okay I'll bring
you some thank you Nucky's no not movies
wait you know these is like that yeah
what are you doing what the [ __ ] is
going on dude yo you and your [ __ ]
towel shirt need to shut the [ __ ] up
it's not sure that's good
first of all we're done we're done is
dopest foot yeah no it's not you just
look like static dude once I gave me one
of these shirts is it my fault that I
just don't want basic T's anymore I like
it like this it's a sweater that they
cut out for me all right Dave 52 years
old from Ontario Canada he works at
McDonald's he's selling the six-year-old
at McDonald's he bought a meal or he had
his daughter buy him a meal from
McDonald's cuz he heard that they never
go bad like the fries and the burger and
so six years ago he brought it and he's
put it on a shelf oh my gosh waited but
then the cabinet plate like the actual
place where the Shelf was they sold that
piece of furniture and so that's when he
came across it again he was like oh yeah
zero that is disgusting what is that
blue mold is that mold in the bun it
looks bad
oh the Lantana you say that they live on
a farm and throughout all these years
like flies never approached it flies
though on it yeah he also made homemade
burgers oh [ __ ] Harrison so this is what
the homemade burger that looks gross
after six years
oh that's intact - exactly that's why
it's such a mean
Oh oh that was a that was a dirty
homemade burger dude this is a six year
old homemade burnt so he had a mcdonalds
and a homemade intact
oh yeah but he is saying like the cheese
isn't there I mean it's no let's see the
cheese not is the bread homemade or like
part of it like it fell apart yeah a
little part yeah the bread homemade his
guys smart because he also had his like
control or whatever you know in the
experiment or whatever another control
bit like that yeah you know what's
interesting is I thought when things
grow mold the mold plates it really eats
everything and then makes it go to not
probably awesome but that doesn't even
have mold it just has dust
what's that black bingo here's the thing
I don't think we actually know this [ __ ]
no no no I don't think that it's just
like it just discipline I thought it was
a whole from here also - it was probably
kept in a place that was very very dry
so moisture also [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up yeah absolutely
I don't know I like seeing this now
because I always felt like McDonald's
was indestructible but now it's just any
processed [ __ ] so I'm like alright
there's a lot of these are
indestructible no I feel a bit more
comfortable because it just felt like
McDonald's was the only one that there
should never get bad but now there's
like three year old chips why would I do
that why would you do that so when I was
a kid my mom they really buy snacks very
frequently and then sometimes you just
get really hungry and I started going
the back of I've got a little pantry and
I find chips and even though it's three
years old I'm really hungry so I eat
this and then the chips are like kind of
clear like it's from the oil the oil
stain is becomes clear and it tastes
kind of funny really corny
did you eat though you ate the chips the
Tostitos yeah just a little bit cuz i
know if i ate too much pie you're sick
you know canned food like that you don't
need an expiration date it'll it'll
usually preserve for a long time but
then companies do that because they want
you to throw it out and then buy another
one have you guys seen that [ __ ] where
it's like canned turkey and like canned
chicken yeah it's a weird
oh man it's weird why would they do that
is it just an old school [ __ ] like I can
use is it white trash people will buy
anything but anything's can yeah cuz
there's canned cheeseburgers and [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah can't cheeseburgers burn
it's not look you pour it out with fluid
and all that yeah can you look for
kimchi comes out like you're taking your
dick out of the giant crazy Russian
hacker
I don't want wet bread mm-hmm why would
you can a cheeseburger my current
favorite thing to watch now is people
who go camping and they cook on a small
fire box yeah sure they they use all
those canned foods is pretty cool look
at how what that is don't you wet
cheeseburger
oh why would you can't a cheeseburger it
does all kinds of canned stuff to freak
you out I'm done eat canned chili like
no matter what I'll be too but can
cheeseburger do have you seen those
those that show where they have weird
people who have an addiction to only
eating one food no yeah so there's a guy
he can only eat cheeseburgers that's
[ __ ] it it's been eating that for
[ __ ] like 30 years right 100% he
would be better instead dude I saw one
where a guy could only eat pizza every
day I can relate to that guy three meals
a day and and then the doctors were like
you're gonna die and he's like you know
what the best episode is in that same
series there's a girl who could not stop
eating cornstarch
this is the opening scene she's hiding
in her car they open the doors she goes
you see that [ __ ] where the girl like
eats her couch like she cuts her couch
of squares and she [ __ ] eats her
count my you see the lady that dating
toilet paper yeah and she'll get a
square at a time she stays like she like
it sticks on her tongue in it she just
eats it like it's a fish flake yeah it's
tough I could see we the people eat like
ceramic plates I don't know how it
develops because there was a guy that
specifically only eats food with a
ridiculous amount of vinegar like he'll
get boiled spaghetti you know put it
into a [ __ ] salad bowl this big full
of red vinegar you'll eat the noodles
and then drink all of it
the doctor was like Burton Eagle on the
inside so what I love about half I would
say 90% of this stuff is that there it's
always like he's eaten bricks his whole
life you'll need cement every day and
then they hook him up to the machine to
have a doctor and he's like yeah 100%
fine yes I don't know why but you've
eaten rocks every day and you're fine
but you really should stop doing this
yeah exactly that's what I'm always like
I'm like dude cuz we don't know [ __ ] man
why did ya for some reason his body's
working around he built the persistence
he can eat [ __ ] rocks you need a
queer Nimrod the vinegar well guy was
pretty funny though because like he had
like a bunch of ulcers stub it look like
a bunch of party Oh like you should
probably stop but that's what I love
about it is the parts with it like I
can't stop eating rocks it's something
that you should it sounds like something
that you should be able to give up
because it sounds gross yeah like I
can't stop eating sad I love eating sad
you got to see like the reaction when
they give them a like a spinning wheel
cut like this a psychologist there right
and they'll give them like a spinning
wheel of food and it'll just be a
different color than a hamburger and
it's just they're eating broccoli just
balling their eyes out overreacting is
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] child did so good my
other favorite shows this is 90 day
fiancé
oh my god what you guys watch it on
Netflix er I saw I just watch on YouTube
and I'm just trying to find full
episodes everywhere cuz I don't [ __ ]
have to you anymore it's about those
shows aren't cut and edited to be funny
but they are hilari no they are no the
the editors are geniuses geniuses they
deserve every [ __ ] single award
because like this show 90 day fiancé is
about Americans who go overseas to get
people who are out of their league
because they didn't want citizenship
oh my god like Russian bride all of it
but like hot people right yeah like
everyone is hot and like their what the
creepy dude that because they're fatter
[ __ ] weird or they're weird
or they're like I mean like there are
like dudes who like are like like hello
I like you oh Jesus bit and they don't
think you look like they're sweating
profusely as they speak to them they
can't figure out why they've never been
able to make it work with chicks and
dudes and like like this is one like
cool two ladies yeah this is a super
overweight lady who's dating this like
this like hot dude from Morocco yeah it
was like you're so fat I just think
you're disgusting like me for my insides
and [ __ ] like that it's great I like
people
great and then there's this [ __ ]
weird dude who's trying to like marry
like basically the hottest chick on
earth right does this have anything he
gets her in New America they have 90
days to get married or else they have to
go home and so it's all about like the
strife of that and and like he brings
hot girl home to meet parents and like
they're like from the Midwest or
whatever and she's wearing like halter
tops and like boy shorts and [ __ ] and
the moms like new Jesus like it's
incredible so it's like a hooker honor
lasts like their last layaway but they
got I still suck it up and just cross
that finish line get that [ __ ]
American citizenship and then they can
do whatever like that is one of the most
[ __ ] up realities TV shows ever
there's like they're geniuses man Tanya
do these the Learning Channel is Jesus
are these people so [ __ ] delusional
they don't know it's about making fun of
them yes they think it's about I'm gonna
be on a mission to find love they're
always shocked and they go on Twitter
sprees after the show premieres because
they can't believe that the producers
dictum so how did you know a lot of
these people they commit suicide
afterwards I do I realize that they're
real people but I don't care I really
hate there's [ __ ] a billion of us
they're willing to exploit people like
this like dangle citizenship over their
mouth exactly that's why it's okay to
laugh out of Zak yeah I'm okay with oh
they deserve it yeah it's so funny
[Music]